oh my god you look stunning look at you  I was like where I have to eat and his  yeah Selena Gomez looked amazing in her  red leather louisvuitton dress at  Tuesday night's UNICEF ball and she has  a lot to celebrate  and I see  pretty soon her song same old love has  reached number one on the charts Selena  told ET she's gearing up for her revival  tour starting in May I'm so excited it's  gonna be big I haven't toured in two  years it's gonna be not bigger  production wise it's gonna be really  emotional I want it to be real and I  want it to feel like they're a part of  the experience with me so it's gonna be  good hopefully we won't get me to get my  ticket please do